n'as tu es petit salon sol actuel et
chéri vous allez voir vous allez devoir
déviner des actus qui vont être joués
par les chroniqueurs qui reprennent les
personnages cultes les petites annonces
d'elie semoun alors il sera miens ils
ont bon goût c'est la toujours je sais
que ça va être mal joué c'est pourquoi
des ordres dans la tristesse et de
l'indulgence s'ils allaient jouer avec
attention
on commence il faut trouver une actu qui
s'est passé ce week-end on commence avec
la féminine rodriguez avec valérie et
gérad moment tristesse rodriguez père et
fils father and sun nous sommes
techniciens du cinéma depuis plus de 150
ans nous pouvons vous faire des
bruitages de type de la famille à l'idée
olalalala omari si tu savais papa je
crois qu'on se ressemble
100 % à que j'ai donné tous le deuil à
laëtitia mais oulalalala il est où mon
héritage a que dans ton cul mme aubry
[Applaudissements]
c'est apparemment ce parce qu'avec
franck dubosc on faisait deux mcs qui
jouait mal mais elle elle joue mal elles
font les gens qui jouent mal et c'est
bien ce salon bien on dirait qu'elles
ont des pressions alors qu'elle est la
classe il faut jouer quand même que les
actus c'est l'intéressé l'année dans le
parisien c'est l'interview qu'il a
donnée qui vit dans le parisien ah non
non c'est david hallyday n'aurait oui on
va revenir sur la faire à l'idée puisque
la réponse est hélas faire à l'idée avec
l'interview de david hallyday au
parisien ce week end david hallyday le
fils de johnny et de sylvie vartan a
donné une interview au parisien pour la
première fois depuis le décès de son
père il s'est notamment exprimé sur la
raison qui le pousse à demander un droit
de regard sur l'utilisation de l'oeuvre
de johnny il dit c'est mon père je
trouve ça normal avec une telle carrière
c'est normal que son fils sa fille comme
ses deux autres petites filles est un
droit de regard dessus
c'est la logique même je ne vois pas
dans quel pays ce ne serait pas logique
et aussi parce que je suis musicien il
m'a toujours fait écouter ses albums
avant qu'ils sortent au moins en partie
david s'est également expliqué sur autre
chose il a dit
d'abord il a également expliqué pourquoi
ne s'est pas exprimé depuis la
disparition de son père c'est normal
d'abord quand on perd approche on
souffre tous de la même façon je ne vois
pas ce que je pourrais dire et puis mes
sentiments les choses importantes je les
fais passer dans ce que je sais faire de
mieux dans des chansons voilà et il dit
aussi qu'il aurait aimé refaire il
aurait aimé refaire un album avec lui il
dit que son père lui manque
voilà et voilà donc c'était une
interview vraiment inédite un vrai
bolide et il est également de 50 minutes
inside
oui je n'ai corps avec lui il dit à la
fois que c'est logique une aubaine
beaucoup je suis d'accord
c'est la logique a qu'un enfant puisse
écouter l'album posthume de son père l'a
déjà coûté deux titres dans la voiture
il avait révélé qu'il avait une voix
extrêmement cristalline et d'autre part
il met pas de côté
jade et joy dans cette affaire il leur
dit que tous les enfants dans leur
intégralité peuvent accéder à l'hommage
posthume de leur père franchement il
mérite ça comme ben oui les interviews
elle est vraiment intéressante parce que
j'ai trouvé qu'elle était pas henneuse
ni agressive c'est vrai il prend
position
c'est sa vérité et c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant l'argumentaire sur la
chanson il argumente très bien pour dire
on doit avoir le droit moral médias que
nous avons écouté les titres alors y
avait sa mère ainsi les vartan qui donne
un livre en concert au rex vendredi
dernier bien sûr une grande partie de ce
concert rendez hommage à johnny hallyday
a eu amoureux du hommage dans un
discours
regardez toute une génération et un
début de révolution et nous on l'a tous
suivi pendant 20 ans lui et moi
on a grandi ensemble voilà elle a alors
rendu hommage à johnny notamment en
chantant aussi un duo virtuel avec
johnny sur scène j'ai un problème
voilà donc ça continue à la faire à
l'idée oui jean michel je ne nie
évidemment pas la tristesse d un réseau
qui est vraiment très très peiné par la
mort de leur père évidemment voilà mais
je suis quand même un peu amusé au las
de voir qu'à chaque fois qu'ils
s'expriment c'est pour réclamer une part
soit de 80 artistes et leurs maris donc
j'ai bien compliquer de l'argent ne les
intéresse pas du tout ils veulent pas
leur part du gâteau
ils veulent que l'héritage artistique je
note mes avocats des initiales je suis
allé voir si c'était un hommage
bouleversant pardon j'avais été voir le
concert c'était magnifique un hommage
bouleversant à johnny évidemment à aucun
moment n'a fait allusion évidemment vu
l'élégance de sylvie david à l'hommage
de l héritage en tout cas c'était
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour que je prenne deux millions
je n'entends pas il ya des jours où on
peut faire une allusion l art est
évidemment non annoncé
c'est une grande élégance et bernard
voyer la la c'est normal
david attoub a aussi dit oui je sais que
j'ai pu mais david et moi en fait vous
allez démarrer tous vos phrases
en fait j'aurais pas cru je suis
insensible à leur peine je me suis
évidemment je comprends très bien leur
peine voilà mais qu'elle a commandé une
bataille d'avocats
il ya aussi malheureusement d'autres
choses qui rentrent en compte et vous
allez dire que david et idées sort de
son silence
il est quand même un tout petit peu gêné
aux entournures parce qu'il conteste un
peu la légalité du geste amant qui a été
fait aux états unis alors évidemment il
part s'installer au portugal pour
échapper à peu la loi française
donc il est un peu gêné quand même de
cette situation voilà vous êtes surpris
mais on les paie mais plutôt rare
pardon mais en fait tu fait l'interview
d'une interview complètement fantasmes
et parce que rien de ce que tu es digne
ne se retrouvent non merci ça s'appelle
des infos ici vous êtes au courant que
vous êtes tous fous en fait
je viens ici par l allemande parallèle
vous êtes dans un monde publie alors
tous fous on a là répond on à honda on a
quelqu'un en tout cas qu'un message pour
vous qui vous dites m'a dit je sais
maintenant dans quel camp vous êtes ici
un autre c'est bon alors à passer à la
deuxième petite annonce